CAROLINA WILL FACE OFF ONE BY
PHILADEL
LOCKER ROOM. ASIDE
BY ANDERSEN.
SWEPT AWAY FROM THE FRONT OF THE
NET.
JACCOB SLAVIN AT THE LINE.
TIPPED BY FRANCIS
HERE FOR A LONG TIME NOW THE
FARABEE AND SHOT BY KEVIN HAYES
AND
COULDN'T PERFORM VERY WELL.
HE LOST THE NET TO JANHEIM FROM
FOR A TIP AND GETS ONE.
AND A SHOT RIGHT ON BY NECAS OFF
TH
IS BACK IN ACTION TODAY, BEEN
SCRATCHED 500th NHL POINT.
TOP OF THE FIRST ROUND..
I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED WITH THEM IN
THE FIRST EIGHT OT FROM THE POI.
SQUEEZED BY JONES.
>> Sean: HERE'S KONECNY LOCKED
DOWN BY ANDERSEN. ANDERSEN BIG
6'5" STAYS DEC
HE TURNS AROUND LATE.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT AS HE CROSS
BAR.
PERHAPS THE LEFT GOALPOST S
ANDERSEN, GOES WIDE, OH, WHAT A
>> Sean: WE SHALL SEE.
SECOND PERIOD UNDER  COMING HER
THE PUCK IS FROZEN BY FREDDIE
ANDERSEN. PUCK IS BOUNCING AROU.
A GOOD SHOT BY
SVECHNIKOV AGAIN IN ALONE AND
MISSED THE NET.
TO GO BLOCKER, IT HITS THE SHAF
CAROLINA LEAD.STEPAN IN HIS NHL
FURTHER WITH ME.
HAYES, NICE MOVE AND PUTS A SHOT
RIGHT AND IT'S
CAREER GOAL NUMBER 200 FOR THE
ANDERSEN WON'T LOVE.
IT'S A SLOPPY REBOUND
CAN CAROLINA EXTEND ITS HOME
WINNING STREAK
THERE'S A GREAT CHANCE DOWN LOW
FOR STEPAN. FOUND ITS WAY IN FO
DELTOID OF MARTIN JONES AND IT'S
IT AWAY FOR CAROLINA, NOW SOURCD